you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's program
india's prime minister narendra modi
will attend cop 26 raising hopes he
might announce an ambitious emissions
target at the summit
it comes as u.s intelligence agencies
are warning that global warming will
increase geopolitical tensions
the city's dirty secret an exclusive
report reveals household banks are
investing billions of pounds into firms
linked to deforestation
and the welsh government says climate
change threatens to increase the dangers
posed by disused coal mines
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now the indian prime minister narendra
modi will be attending the cop 26
climate summit in glasgow now just 10
days away more than 120 world leaders
are expected to attend the talks in
person although several prominent
figures including russia's president
putin will not be there mr modi's
attendance raises hopes that india will
use the summit to announce more
ambitious climate action plans sky's
neville lazarus has the latest from
delhi
india's environment and climate change
minister has confirmed that prime
minister modi will attend the un summit
on climate change cop 26 in glasgow
india is a third worst emitter of
greenhouse gases after after china and
the united states and having the country
represented by prime minister modi will
be a big boost for the world's efforts
in cutting emissions
and fighting global warming prime
minister modi has often spoken of india
not only achieving its paris agreement
targets but his government's endeavors
to go beyond that he has spoken of
decoupling economic growth from
greenhouse gas emissions
his government has has put in a lot of
resources and efforts into renewable
energy particularly the solar sector
where large gigawatt farms have come up
during his tenure but it is a long way
to go as more than half of india's gdp
is dependent solely on coal and fossil
fuel
most of india lives in its villages
and civ and is attached to agricultural
land severe weather conditions and and
events have an effect on the lives and
livelihoods of millions of people just
this week alone toronto rains have
caused flash floods and
and landslides killing scores of people
in the states of kerala and uttarakhand
and these severe weather events are
increasing every year not only with the
numbers but also the intensity
prime minister modi has a majority in
the indian parliament he does not shy
away from taking bold and decisive
decisions even though they may not be
popular and having him at glasgow will
be a big boost for the summit
the u.s national security agency is
warning that climate change will
exacerbate long-standing threats to
global security the new national
intelligence estimate report the first
of its kind says geopolitical tensions
continue to grow as countries argue over
the reductions in greenhouse gas
emissions well our u.s correspondent
martha kellner joins us now so the first
report of its kind martha tell us what
it says
yeah it certainly is an inaugural report
anna and i think when you think about
climate change you generally think about
the threats it poses to our existence in
terms of major weather events like
flooding and like droughts like
hurricanes you don't necessarily think
of the threat it poses um to both
national and global security this is as
you mentioned the first report of its
kind released by the white house in
conjunction with the u.s intelligence
community and the pentagon the defense
department it essentially makes three
key assessments of how climate change
poses a threat to security the first is
that tensions are likely to grow between
countries as they increasingly argue as
we're seeing at the moment about how to
reach um their net greenhouse gas
emission targets in accordance with the
paris climate agreement the second
conclusion of this report is that the
physical effects of climate change are
likely to result in what the report
calls geopolitical
cross-border flash points that's as
countries take steps to protect their
own national interests it may be at odds
of the interests of other countries the
third and final key and conclusion of
this report is that the physical effects
of climate change will be felt most
keenly as we know in developing
countries and that's countries that are
less likely to be able to adapt to the
threats posed by climate change and as a
result they'll be increasing instability
and also increasing demands from a us
perspective on humanitarian and military
resources so this is a sweeping report
which paints a very grim picture of how
climate change could affect national and
global
security martha thank you
well let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now and the
thames barrier is closing today for the
200th time since 1982.
the closure of the barrier will reduce
the risk of flooding for up to 640 000
properties in london and along the
thames
combination of spring tides tidal surge
and recent rainfall has led to the
closure
reaching net zero by 2050 is likely to
fail and less education on climate
change is made compulsory that's
according to a report published by the
association of colleges which warns
students must be given the access to
skills needed for green jobs currently
less than one percent of students
currently in post-16 education are on a
course with broad coverage of climate
change
new research has found that a restored
salt marsh in somerset stores more
carbon carbon in four years than one
million trees in ten years research from
manchester metropolitan university also
revealed that the rate at which the
carbon is restored is 18 times higher
than current estimates the uk has over
20 000 hectares of land that could be
restored to salt marsh with the
potential to store 25 000 tons of carbon
some of the world's biggest banks have
invested tens of billions of pounds into
businesses involved with deforestation
that's according to a new report shared
exclusively with sky news that says
banks including jp morgan and hsbc are
making profits from such deals despite
making public commitments to tackle
climate change skies helen smith reports
behind glassy facades in financial
centers lie deals which determine the
flow of money but there are serious
questions about where some of it goes
and what some of it funds
a new investigation shared exclusively
with sky news shows that tens of
billions of pounds is financing work
like this
banks and asset managers investing
underwriting and loaning to agribusiness
linked to deforestation they tell us
they're green institutions but they just
keep doing it the research team analyzed
70 000 deals struck with 20 of the worst
defending businesses they say many banks
profited to the tune of tens of millions
of pounds they're very good at telling
us how green they are but what we found
is this gaping hole between what they
say in public and what they actually do
so when you follow the money and look at
their revenue streams look at their
actions you realize that they're not as
clean as they say they are
in fact since the paris climate
agreement in 2016 financial institutions
in europe the us and china have made
deals worth 120 billion pounds with
firms linked to tropical deforestation
u.s bank jp morgan was the biggest
lender making deals worth over seven
billion pounds while in the uk hsbc was
the biggest financer making deals worth
over five billion
hsbc alone made estimated proceeds of
nearly 30 million pounds from these
deals that's despite a pledge four years
ago to stop financing firms accused of
deforestation
in a statement it said hsbc has exited
is in the process of exiting or has no
banking relationship related to forestry
palm oil or cattle with the majority of
entities named in the report
it says it's ended relationships with
customers that don't comply with its
policies and is committed to tackling
deforestation jp morgan declined to
comment
there's nothing illegal about these
deals but many banks have pledged not to
make them however there's a growing
argument that self-regulation hasn't
worked and what's needed is a change in
the law
the government's flagship environment
bill is due next week a perfect
opportunity according to some
neil parish tabled an amendment to ban
these type of financial deals but it was
rejected the legislation is always
important because you can then go to
these major banks major companies and
actually say you have acted illegally
you must stop and we can take direct
action but even despite all of that the
government rejected your amendment but
that doesn't stop us still thorpy to
government
and i think the government has come a
long way in the environment built
towards the direction we want
cutting down forest not only contributes
to climate change but is devastating to
local communities
cutting off the finance would
substantially cut down the practice
helen and smith sky news
the welsh government says climate change
could increase the risk of landslides
from disused coal tips and is calling on
the uk government to make them safe it
wants more than half a billion pounds
from the uk to carry out work on 327
high-risk tips across wales the call
comes today on what's the 55th
anniversary of the abervan disaster
which left 144 people dead including 116
children a warning dan whitehead's
report includes upsetting details of the
disaster from the
outset with a rumbling noise something
like thunder
which got
louder and louder and the next thing i
remember was waking up with all this
material above me
and there was a dead girl on
my left shoulder
jeff edwards was eight years old when he
walked into pankglass junior school in
abervan
just minutes later a cold tip on the
hills above slid
engulfed the classroom
and killed 116 children
and 28 adults
because it affected me my childhood
ended then
the majority of the children in my class
died so there were no really friends to
play with after that
and
obviously it was the psychological
injuries that occurred in the
and the guilt of being alive compared to
those who had died
was a huge burden to bear
and still is to a certain extent today
the pain in abivan remains
those lost never forgotten
55 years on there are still around two
and a half thousand disused coal tips in
wales more than 320 of them at high risk
whoa
in february last year storm dennis
caused a landslide of
000 tons of coal waste in the village of
tyler's town the welsh government fears
how a changing climate could lead to
more slips like this
and it's a worry for locals nothing is
stable around you no no
debris from the pets is stable around
you
so really
something has to be done
inspections are being carried out but
there's an increasing growl over who
should ultimately pay the bill
maintaining coal pits is the
responsibility of the welsh government
but it says that the coal mined here
fueled the industrial boom right across
the country
pre-devolution and so the money to make
these areas safe again
should come from the uk government
if it doesn't the welsh government says
the money will have to come from
elsewhere we'd have to look again at
school programs road maintenance
that plans for hospital building and so
on so there are real life implications
of the uk government not stepping up to
the plate
downing street says wales is already
more than adequately funded
while some tips like this one have been
regenerated the fact remains that
hundreds more are untouched
an industry long gone
has left a dangerous legacy
damn whitehead sky news
in south wales
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'll be joined by economist vicky
price and bob ward from the grantham
research institute and we're going to be
discussing how important it is for world
leaders to actually attend cop26 and
whether climate change education should
be compulsory for students
[Music]
a meeting is next tuesday at the fda
well the where they will review the data
from pfizer
showing that at one third the dose that
is 10 micrograms they get an equivalent
immune response to older uh individuals
ages 16 to 25.
uh fewer side effects and at least
initially and so it appears good to go i
think most people are behind this
including the american academy of
pediatricians the already school
mandates uh proposed for one year from
now in california and hopefully other
states will follow there were protests a
a couple of days ago in california where
there was a
sit out where school kids stayed at home
on their parents desires and protested
in major cities in california that
mandate uh proposed one year from now
but if you look at the data only about
one-third of parents actually
vehemently uh oppose any uh vaccinating
vaccination of their kids age five to
eleven uh about one-third will say
they'll go out immediately and vaccinate
their kids and about forty percent will
watch and wait
we do know that vaccine mandates have
been working in in the us uh take for
example
the los angeles unified school district
about a month ago they're about uh maybe
80
60 or
70 percent of
uh
school staff and teachers vaccinated the
deadline was on monday and by monday
there were 97 of the school staff and
teachers vaccinated so we do believe
that the carrots only work to some
regard
lotteries a shot for a shot ice cream
donuts uh at the end of the day mandates
have really moved the dial much more in
the united states so far
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
did you know if you use less energy we
can reduce air pollution
like turning off the light
[Music]
the morning will be fine for most but
there'll be showers around mainly for
northern and central parts expect some
winter-ness on the hills in the far
north it shouldn't feel quite as cold as
yesterday with the raw wind becoming
confined to north sea coastal areas
the afternoon we'll see showers fading
but they'll keep going over wales and
central england into the evening
the clean cold air means that the air
pollution index where one means low
pollution and 10 means very high will be
low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
economist vicki price and policy
director at the grantham research
institute on climate change bob ward so
good to see you both good evening to you
both
so with just 10 days to go until cop 26
it's been confirmed that india's prime
minister narendra modi will travel to
glasgow for the summit downing street
has welcomed the news saying india has a
vital role in making the event a success
but who really holds the power to create
change so bob how significant do you
think it is that narendra modi is
heading to glasgow
well it is very significant because it
raises the prospect that he may make a
major announcement about india's
emissions at the moment we haven't seen
a revised more ambitious pledge from
india which all countries were supposed
to bring forward before glasgow but the
fact that he'll be in glasgow in person
means that he may make an announcement
and some of the discussion has been
about the possibility of india
committing to a net zero target getting
its emissions down to zero perhaps by
2060. so all of this is very exciting
well yes that's right and it's true
isn't it that india hasn't yet announced
plans to reach net zero so vikki
india's under pressure to make that move
if they were to
would that put pressure on other
countries like china to take
a different stance and to up their game
well the interesting thing is of course
that china has already announced that
they are also aiming for net zero by
2060 so it would be india that would be
following more what china has done
already but the reality is that quite a
lot of other developing countries might
look at that and and realize that they
can't be out on their own really in this
area but there is going to be a price i
think that is going to be extracted for
pledging net zero for india it is after
all the third largest um carbon emission
uh country in the world and and of
course it will cost it a lot to move
away from its over reliance for example
right now still on coal despite the the
progress that it has made in terms of
renewables so it is going to be asking
for cash i'm pretty certain all other
conditions to be met that will be
beneficial to india if it is indeed
going to move in that direction it
cannot do it i think on the basis of
where things are at present well yes and
climate finance is going to be a huge
part of the discussion in glasgow isn't
it bob so india's presence how does that
affect that debate and how does that
feed into everything else
well india is a developing country it's
much poorer than the rich countries and
what it's saying to the world is look
at the moment it costs more for it to to
access capital to make the kind of
investments needed in renewables and
others and it's it's that capital is
more expensive because it's considered
to be a more risky place to do it and
because renewable energy is considered
more risky so it's going to say to the
rich world please help us access this
capital so that we can access it the the
private sector will make money on this
because it's built it will be building
an energy system that will generate
returns so it should be uh an attractive
prospect both for the private sector and
the public sector and we all benefit if
india does start to limit its emissions
okay we're going to move on to the next
topic now and earlier on the show we
heard how college leaders are calling on
the government to make lessons on global
warming compulsory they say the uk is
unlikely to reach its net zero target
without change so how do we put climate
change into the curriculum um vicky to
you first of all then and just to give
you a statistic less than one percent of
students are on a course with broad
coverage of climate education you can
see that fact there so how important do
you think it is to have climate change
in education for those over 16.
i think it's very important but of
course there are two aspects of climate
change education one is to make people
aware of what the issues are so they
behave in a different way themselves to
the future more responsibly the other
one is to upgrade their skills or make
sure that the skills in the curriculum
that exists
are fit for whatever it is that we want
to do in the future the green jobs that
are being announced for example with a
net zero strategy an extra 450 000
supposedly which has been a figure that
we've been talking about for the past 15
years in my memory um so it is really
whether we're talking about upskilling
and if we know really what those skills
are likely to be needed and which they
are going to be needed in the future
that we not quite sure at present given
that technology is still
unclear and uh there could be all sorts
of areas of activity that will be taking
place in the future that we can't even
imagine right now so the question is
what do we upscale our people for and
are we basically talking about
everything being done in a green way in
other words
having a lot less emission for every
ounce of
production that we have in the future
rather than the way we do things at
present so a bit of an unknown there if
you're going to be teaching it what
exactly are you going to be telling your
students bob do you think that's a fair
point
yes but it's important to remember that
students before 16 already
are taught about climate change as part
of the national curriculum both in
science and in geography so beyond 16
it's a conversation about what how to
put it in not just in science and in
environment but also in in other
subjects such as economics and law and i
know that students at lse for instance
london school of economics where i am
really do want to learn more about
climate change and the way it's
affecting all aspects of our lives and
our economy well that's so interesting
isn't it vicky and some people might say
this this idea is pushing at an open
door i mean we've seen all the school
strikes a lot of those children actually
younger than 16 but there is an
enthusiasm you might say amongst younger
people that it's perhaps not there in
some of the older generations
the interesting thing is that when you
do surveys about climate change and
awareness and whether you want to do
something about it we find that all
generations in the uk certainly seem to
be quite committed to it and understand
the issues so it's not just confined to
any particular age group but what
worries me is that there has been this
huge cut in funding for further
education in other words
risking the older population those who
may need to change their jobs or the way
they do their jobs and that funding
needs to be restored if we are at all
serious about ensuring that population
we have at prison who is in the labor
force uh and always about to get into
the labor force is able to deal with
things for the future okay vicki price
bob ward we're out of time good to see
both thanks very much indeed for joining
us at this evening
that's everything from us for today
joining us on the show tomorrow is
climate activist michaela loach and tom
burke chairman of the e3g think tank
do stay tuned here on sky news though
because coming up next as the daily
number of covered cases tops at 50 000
the prime minister resists calls for new
restrictions and instead urges people to
get a booster jab do stay tuned see you
next time
[Music]